(laughter)
- We wrote the same thing.
- That's crazy.
That's crazy.
- Yeah.
- That's some BFF shit right there.
- Dang.
I want you to be my president.
- Yeah, you are my president.
- We're so much better
friends, than we are with him.
- Yeah we are better friends.
(upbeat rock)
- Hey.
- What's up?
- How's it goin?
- We're here at Buzz Feed.
- About to take the BFF test.
- I'm excited.
- You know?
- What do BFF stand for?
- I don't know.
- Best friends, fuckhead.
- Okay well, they're gonna blerp that.
- Oh, I hate cursive.
Oh, that's easy.
- I'm basing this off of when he like
fucks up a take on the show.
- Yeah.
- Too short bitch.
- Yeah, that is true,
you sing that the most.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- You don't sing "fuck"
but, but you say it.
- Yeah, I do love that one to
be fair, fuck's pretty sick.
- Yeah, that is a good one.
- I feel like all of your
talents, you've done.
- No, there's ones you
don't even know about dude.
- Wait till you see.
- Uh, okay.
(laughter)
- Nope.
- Wrong.
(laughter)
- Yeah.
- Ah, Please (says in French)
- Dude! I got it.
- Yeah!
- That's not a secret.
- Oh man, yes!
Not many people know, the dude it good.
- Not many people know how
good I am at hacky sack.
- Well, no one knows how
good at French you are,
including you.
- Including myself.
Yeah, if only I studied it ever.
- Yeah.
- Just break us off with a little.
- Hon-hon-hon, French bread, cheese.
- Dude, it's German, needs more of German.
- I speak German good. (speaks in German)
- Impressed.
- Yeah, see.
(writing on paper)
(laughter)
- [Narrator] One, two three flip.
- Are you guys both have "makes me seem."
Now I have like some sort of
underground hip hop knowledge.
- Right, right, right, backpack rap.
- Backpack rapper.
- Yeah, I said, "Makes me seem smarter."
Make me seem smarter.
- Yeah, I feel like I
make you guys feel normal.
- Make me. (laughing)
- [Blake] Seem.
- [Anders] Alright,
you spelled seem right.
- [Blake] Yeah.
- I had to think about it.
- Uh, little bit of a high from this.
- That's weird.
- Little contact high from these Sharpies.
- Yeah, this is really powerful.
- Now I know why you
guys are Buzz Feed, whoa.
(laughter)
- I just smoked weed earlier.
- That's really good.
- Seem high, am high.
- Am currently, I am.
(upbeat pop music)
- I'm not even gonna write
it, I'm just gonna say Shaggy.
- Sure.
- Shaggy.
- Yeah, we're done writing.
- Yeah, I'll say it.
- Wait, no.
- Your guilty pleasure song.
- What is it?
Just tell us, just tell us dude.
We're not writing it, so
you might as well tell us.
- You just wanna know it?
- Yeah.
- No Scrubs.
- [Adam] Oh.
- [Anders] No Scrubs
- Yeah.
- Do you feel guilty about liking that?
- Well because, I feel like I am a scrub
and I feel bad about like,
calling out my people.
- Right, cuz you're a no pigeons guy.
- Yeah, I'm a no pigeons guy.
- Right, yeah.
("No Pigeons" by Sporty Thievz)
- Look it up, it was good,
I hope you guys know.
- It was a hit, it was a weird hit.
- But No Scrubs.
- Not a hit actually.
- No, not at all.
- No, not a hit.
(upbeat pop music)
- I'm gonna allow them to answer this one.
Yep, this is right.
What Anders is writing is correct.
- Dang, that's pretty good.
- Lakers win champ while car.
(laughter)
- Oh, Blake your sentence
game is at an all time low.
- That's like 100 years
ago on Workaholics.
- That was Workaholics, were
talking about the new movie.
We're promoting "Game Over, Man!"
- Oh, shit.
- Can't talk about our whole lives.
- Hold on, my bad.
- But what was fun.
- That was cool.
- We're getting pulled in like
a car, you know like they.
- It was season one of
Workaholics, and we listened
to the championship
basketball game on the radio
while we were shooting
it, and that was great.
But yeah, having them stare at my dick,
while I had it out for
this movie was um...
- For a day.
- For a full day.
- [Blake] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I like that answer.
(Anders laughs)
- Permission to pee myself is, our smiles.
I just wrote, feeling something.
- Yeah.
(Blake laughs)
- He dies inside when we're not around.
- Yeah.
- Wow, that's really nice.
- Hey, I give you permission pal.
- Living around everyone else, I'm like
Yeah, I'm Anders, hey-oh.
- [Narrator] - Now you guys need to flip.
- This is a quote from Big
Trouble in Little China.
- Yeah, that is pretty good.
- I don't know if he'd actually send it.
- Okay, wait what?
New phone who dis?
(laughter)
Oh you asked me over the phone, okay.
- [Adam] Yeah, I asked you over the phone.
- Yeah.
- Okay yeah, I don't got it.
- Over a text.
- Yeah.
- Respect, now I know why
they call it Buzz Feed.
- Yeah, I didn't like that
one, I did not like that one.
- That was shoe horned.
- Yeah that one was a little personal.
- That one was shoe horned,
the rest have been great.
- Now I know why it's called Budz Feed.
(laughter)
- It is called Budz Feed, right?
- Budz Feed, right?
- Oh man,
how did we not start that
cuz it's like weed centric.
- Yeah alright, well we have
a competitive site that were starting.
Sorry Buzz Feed.
(classical jazz music)
- Chugging Red Bull, awe it
depends how long the break is.
- Yeah that's true, I do play
"2K," nap and slam caffeine.
- Yeah, it's either or.
He's either asleep or wide awake
- There's no in between.
- No, and that's why
we call him Buzz Feed.
- He's either eating or drinking Red Bull.
Buzzin or feeding.
(classical jazz music)
- [Narrator] Ready, flip.
(laughter)
- [Blake] It's supposed to be a thumbs up.
- Just uh, the weirdest nut sack.
(Adam laughing loudly)
- You ever see a dick
with a fingernail on it?
(laughter)
- You did a dick too?
- No, I thought it was
supposed to be a thumbs up.
- Yeah.
Ders has this secret
emoji of just a dick that
That I feel like he should start to use.
- Inbound.
- I blew it.
- This one saves the day, er-day.
- What is my pet peeve?
- Uh well, remember that
phase that I was goin through
where I'd come up and sneak up on you guys
and kiss your shoulders.
(laughter)
- Did I not like that?
- Yeah, I don't think he likes that one.
- That was a cool cool, cool bit.
- That was a cool, cool bit.
- What the fuck are you doing?
- Yeah, it was a fun bit that I had.
- We're in public.
- That no one else liked.
- Blakes pet peeve?
- [Adam] Yeah, no peeve, peeve less.
- I'm just gonna just show mine, none.
- Yeah.
- I got none.
- [Adam] This guy's peeve less.
- Adam.
- You're room is messier than mine.
- Is it?
- [Adam] Yeah.
- I just remember when
we lived together, lots
of dishes stacking up.
- I don't do dishes.
So, me I'll take it, sure.
- I'm not.
- You're not messy?
- I'm not messy?
- Well, you fold your fast
food wrappers, you do.
- So.
- Yeah.
- That, that immediately
says your not messy.
- Okay.
- Blake
- Blake the flake.
- Blake the flake, it
rhymes so it has to be it.
- Uh Devine, come on, he's
got that pitch perfect swang.
- Yeah, I do have that swang,
yeah, but that hair will get
you in.
Ders could talk you into the club, yeah.
He'll get you in using
your whits and bravado.
- Hey uh, can we get in there or not?
- No, okay.
- Remember the time I got us in by going
- We're on Stephanie's
list, and somehow it worked.
- Evidently there was a
Stephanie in there with a list.
- At every bar.
- Remember in Vegas, when
you tried to convince them
you were a cast member of SNL?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- Andy Bovine
- [Adam] Yeah, this is before.
- That's like 2004.
- Yeah, we were children.
- That didn't work.
- Me probably.
- Adam, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, believe it
or not uh, Blake isn't.
I had to push Blake down the weed path.
- Yeah, you've been smoking way longer.
You got me into it,
gateway drug though so.
- Yeah
- So, thanks Adam.
- Hey guys, nope that was stupid.
(Narrator laughs)
- It's okay, it's okay.
- Okay.
- No I went with a "hey guys"
there's women out there.
Hey, what's up people.
- Human of earth.
- [Blake] Wat up everybody.
- Yeah, what's up all
the people out there.
- Yep.
- Uh, we're the guys
from "Game Over, Man!"
and "Workaholics" and were saying bye.
- See ya.
- I didn't like what I did
at the end with the bye.
I held on too many "Es."
- Dude you're fine, you're
being critical of yourself.
- Thank you.
- It was bad.
- You're doin great.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for being honest.
- And a little kissing
on the. (kissing sound)
(Adam laughs loudly)
- Oh, its too, I get why
you guys didn't like it.
- Yeah it's weird it sends
shivers down your spine.
- [Adam] Yeah, yeah.
- [Anders] I don't know.
- [Adam] That was a weird
phase I was going through.
(upbeat pop music)